une maison historique construite en 1781
au bord du richelieu
la visite bien documenté d'un presse
britannique à sorel en septembre 1787 et
des fouilles archéologiques menées en
juin dernier je sais des quais bello un
paquet d'objets c'est s'adapter du
xviiie siècle pour moi c'est un
potentiel d'un trésor archéologique qui
se trouve à cet endroit nos marques et
aux log yves chrétien débarque à sorel
tracy en 2017 pour sonder le terrain
autour de la maison des gouverneurs
avant que lavillenie phase des travaux
d'aménagement 40 coup de sonde dont un
plein de promesses sous l'île où des
drapeaux rendu à un mètre 5 tout d'un
conte j'arrive dans une masse de
matériel melo il y en avait ce avait
aucun sens tout était mélangé la poterie
le vent et relie les ossements d'animaux
l'éco conduite la table est mise pour
raconter une histoire fantastique que la
ville de sorel tracy a d'abord partagé
avec les citoyens et ouvre la voie à
qu'elle avait trouvé mais là c'est plus
que ce qu'on s'attendait c'est ce qui
est surprenant qu'ils aient pu réussir à
avoir autant de morceaux qui pouvoir
toutes les rumeurs ensemble le fond des
latrines identifiés en 2017 a donc
révélé ses trésors l'été dernier quand
les archéologues sont revenus faire une
fouille complète on avait une cible est
la cible elle est l eau quand on faisait
la fouille on trouve et au delà c'est ce
qui était fracturée le mais les morceaux
étaient toutes en articulation la danse
et les dix que les pièces ont été jetés
complète dans la fosse tel quel on
arrive à plus de 40 bouteilles de
la quantité l'oignon puis la qualité des
pièces qu'il est aussi le maire de sorel
tracy aussi est impressionné c'est du
clae - ça c'est une céramique et en
vogue à cette époque le dans les années
1780 les morceaux tête à son
articulation c'est que ja ont jeté la
vaisselle
semblait willich ttotte un comportement
plutôt intriguant alors c'est un
comportement qui a une signification et
l'ajustement se pose la question mais
qu'est ce que sexo la vaisselle les
bouteilles y la variété des résidus de
table révèle le caractère inusité de ce
banquet et l'importance des convives
d'autres indices comme le type de cloud
utilisés ont permis d'établir une
fourchette de temps si on regarde dans
la période de 1786 à 1798 un événement
historique marque s'est déroulée ici et
la réponse est oui oui c'est la présence
la visite du prince william henry le 18
septembre 1715 il reste des recherches
historiques à faire pour confirmer
l'hypothèse du banquet royal c'est
vraiment un trésor c'est vraiment trouvé
vraiment le plus gros cadeau historique
qu'on ne peut pas avoir dans la région
en fait ça vient confirmer vraiment
l'utilisation de la maison ou si la
maison des gouverneurs qu'on appelle
c'est à dire que c'était un vieux
gréement pour les dignitaires de la
province de québec j'espère qu'ils vont
les garder que ça va être en
démonstration pour remontrer aux gens
que ça vient d'ici puis raconter
l'histoire ou sites bancaires
sort elle s'est appelée with ump mme ri
pendant des décennies jusqu'en 1860
aujourd'hui la visite du jeune prince
avant d'être roi de grande bretagne est
devenue beaucoup plus concrète ici à
nourrice despatie radio-canada sorel
tracy
[Musique]